Really available game engines to develop and
mature into powerhouses that make creating
games in them much easier for example Unreal
Engine or Unity now to back up everything
that I'm saying and prove it in this video
I'm going to make a functional belief
playable MMORPG in under 8 hours by spending
less than a hundred USD without writing a
single line of code it's all goes well I
will put a download link in the description
of this video for the client so you'll be
able to download the game open the game
created character and start playing on my
server now for this I'm going to be using
unity and activism I'm using Unity because
of activism being the easiest to use MMORPG
framework right now and it won't be
available in Unreal Engine until the end of
the year but you could do something similar
using other MMORPG Frameworks like you
animal or spatial Os or something like that
the main draw of addipism for this video is
that it has a
Day free trial and then it's 30 a month so
let's get startedMy first step is to just
download and install the latest version of
unity.
The second step is going to be to register
an account for activism and then download
activism client itself for step 3 we need to
make a server that our game world is hosted
on now out of them has a virtual service
that you can just open for free on your own
PC and then connect to it through there for
testing and building the game but I want my
server to be online so other people can
connect and play once I finish this video so
I will be putting it on a server hosting but
it is limited to 100 users
New project in unity and then install the
ativism package the framework basically for
the MMORPG into that new project
Got out of it some comes with its own demo
account creation scene a character creation
scene and a beginner demo starting zone with
three classes some vendors questions Etc so
we'll set it so that it connects to my
server and then we'll try logging in it
looks like the demos working fine I can
connect I can run around in the Demo World
technically I can give you guys this game
client and you'd be able to connect to my
server and play in this mmorp world with me
right now but that's kind of called asset
flipping so we don't want to do that we want
to make our own MMORPG and this demo was
made like 7 years ago and since the
Frameworks gone through like a bunch of new
version and updates most of the stuff here
doesn't even work so let's start making an
MMORPG
Step 5 we are going to need a starter Zone
here we are going to be utilizing cinti our
assets and this is where money may come in
now Cindy's art you might recognize if
you're following Titan reach the kickstarter
MMORPG that's currently raising funds to
develop their game if you haven't back them
I highly recommend you do they seem like a
good bunch of developers because they have
so many assets that cover so many scenario
theme song only making a tiny little demo
for this video I will make the playable area
pretty small using the textures from The
Simpsons
And some plantsThen we'll put in some
camp-like stuff.
I think that looks good enough for a little
tiny starting area
Step 6 we are going to get rid of the demo
main world and then set this as the world a
new character appears in when they log in
for the first time basically this becomes
our playable game area and we'll make sure
this level has everything it needs to work
with out of business which is basically just
copy pasting so still I have not needed to
write a single line of code and there we go
we made a starting zone for our MMO RPG
obviously it's pretty ugly the lighting is
way off I made this in less than 30 minutes
Step 7 is going to be the character creation
the default character just isn't going to
cut it again we
Again we will put in the Cindy modular
characters which comes with a ton of
hairstyles Etc but also redesign the
character selection screen so it's not using
the art assets from the original game
because they just don't look that good with
the Cindy style then we're going to import a
specific tool for activism made by simply
lovers that makes it so that the activism
client immediately free and much more
flexible but because I'm using a lower
polygon style it doesn't make sense you know
you're not tied to this art stuff that's how
easy it is right now to make an animal look
the way you want it to it looks like the
characters working we can move around
already using our character models Scott the
correct animation
Step 8 we need to redo the character
creation you want and make it work with our
new character models following a simple
tutorial so we just add some buttons to the
UI make the buttons trigger something on the
character to change the hair and it is
saving to our character in The Game World so
we are going to go through and add buttons
to customize everything eyebrows beard hair
color skin color eye color basically just
copy pasting and then moving it around
All of it seems to be working pretty fine
though I will admit that it took a good hour
to get this part done DUI looks pretty trash
but Adam is getting an update to manage you
want in the future that'll make changing the
style of all of your buttons and everything
at once super easy and I don't really care
what it looks like for this video
Step 9 we are going to create our first item
on Apple we can go into the editor and
create the item and then customize it to
tell the game what we want the item to do so
for example this apple we want to trigger an
ability when the apple is eaten and the
ability is channeled when you use it so you
can't move and if you move you stop
channeling it so you stop eating basically
and while it's channeling you get hit points
but if you move or if you take damage then
it can't the Apple itself it's going to
pulse three times and it's going to do that
five times so three times 15 it's a 15
second Channel and each of the takes is
going to heal for 5 HP so if you eat the
whole Apple you will get 25 HP over 15
seconds we just have to tell the pulse that
it's going to pulse a self-healing effect
and you can just look while I'm doing this
how customizable the items and abilities are
in this freely usable tool how easy it is to
make whatever skills and ability you can
think of and this one was just a free trial
so just imagine the tools
Guys in lizard or Amazon or cacao are using
and how easy it can be for them to quickly
create this stuff next we will go into our
warrior class and we will delete all the
demo starting items that he starts with and
we just want to have the new character start
with 20 apples after the characters created
we log in with a new character that is a
warrior and we got the apples in the
inventory and we can eat that and they
Channel and they heal obviously there's no
animations or sounds for it yet I can add
that but it's just a whole bunch of time and
I want to get along to work on and stuff
like that through all the modular characters
that we have important already take the
parts that we
Parts that we want our NPC to look like and
we will save it then we just take all the
stuff that Adam and they need to recognize
this as a minute then we
Go into the editor we
Create an event tell it to use the model let
me just created and this is a shopkeeper so
he doesn't we don't really care what the
stats are and if he is an attack ability
right now we just want him to have a shot
inventory tables and will create a inventory
for Joe
I'm going to go ahead and log in as an admin
account and use the admin tool in the game
to put the MPC somewhere in the game world
and make sure that he has that Merchant
table and some dialogue this automatically
saves the spawn on the server side not
client that's why I had to play some during
runtime but all other players in my Game
World can now buy and sell apples to joke
Immunity Marketplace
It's also a beast it's using the correct
model that we set up and everything should
be working me also want to set up a loop
table to decide what the wolf will drop so
we need to create some trash items like
broken fangs fur we also want to make sure
that we can get leather from skinny him so
we'll make some leather and set up a Skinny
mood table as well the wolf is done
I want to have an unarmed strength skill
that's going to level up the more times I
punch people so I'll get stronger the more
time to fight with my fists so I'm going to
make it using ability called on strike which
can work as an auto attack anytime I don't
have a weapon equipped basically anytime I
punch the wolf with the skill I'm going to
get experience in my unarmed strength skill
and when I punch it enough I will level up
my skills and that conscious will hurt more
and I will get possible my first skill that
can grind literally by punching wolves
I'm also going to Tweet the sauce that Adam
is am uses by default it's got 2,000 HP of
the gate for our character but I prefer
smaller numbers so we're going to Nerf all
of these stats way way way down and now
we've got the wolf and the characters down
to roughly 100 HP I can run up I can punch
it the wolf is still moving a little bit
funky because of the same problem the server
doesn't know where the game world war is
I've got no punch animation it just doesn't
lightning effects so basically I'm able to
grind up like this if I wanted to it's a
functionally playable MMO the process to
expand on anything I've done so far is
basically the same I can ask questions and
dialogue and affection and more skills Etc
but there's one more set just to prove that
this is a functioning and the more
I sent the client over to my wife's computer
so she's going to log in and out of business
already got a party system and Guild systems
and framework.com
That it's totally possible for a small team
of hard working debts to be a
A functioning MMORPG on a low budget I'll
try and fix the server navigation to the
Wolves will stop acting weird and I'll put a
link in the description of this video to the
client so you guys can just register and
gain and run around and comfortable for fun
if you would like to just keep in mind my
server is limited to 100%
Simple MMORPG but that's it for this video
as always thank you guys for watching have a
great day I am pooping up
Looking nice man
Come on then she was over 140 countries
Best though that's back upstairs because the
first thing I had to do was to pick a game
engine now the game engine at least in this
instance is a piece of software that helps
you make a game by essentially taking care
of the stuff that's hard and boring about
things like getting graphics
I mean the most popular ones are unity like
twine images
And put it on PlayStation 5 that is
technically possible if not financially
It is the most popular
Nothing like literally nothing nothing they
had said going in one year and out the other
like I couldn't even make a character Appeal
on the screen and move around it was
terrible it was my own thought remember that
video I made about tutorials games
Idiot like I had wasted weeks of my life and
I didn't know
If I was even cut out for game development
like if I can't even watch it shortly
Just pretend and never happened it was it
sucked it was horrible
But then I thought the bank Adobe Premiere
this is the software that I used to make all
the videos on this channel reviews
Tonight but I had two things on my side one
is that I don't need to learn everything all
in Monica as long as I'm always trying at
least one new thing and each video I make I
can slowly build up a breakfast bar of
effects and knowledge video reviews
Learn the answer Basics and nothing more
step two familiarize myself with those
Basics through repetition and simple and
then three slowly over time build a
repertoire of tools in Premiere as I build
and build and build my knowledge test
With my tools
Couldn't comfort with the software to
experiment myself and figure things out
But the context??
????
I'm not starting completely from zero when
it comes to game developed I am familiar
with the fundamentals of programs profile
Learn how to do and yet that's true but it's
enough to get me started I can make stuff
appear on the screen make it move around
make collisions happens and they are these
kind of genre agnostic things that I will
need to know no matter what I make going
forward it is the Baseline that I understand
Google
To worry about art or design or rules or
anything like that that's already done for
you all you need to care about is code and
you get this really clear objective can I
take this game and recreate it immunity by
myself and so the first game I did this with
was was really simple and yes one thing too
Collision so when the bird hits the pipe
that's a game over but if the bird goes
between two points a trigger and as a store
to where you are and so that involves
sending information from one game object to
another fundamental lesson and then I finish
it off with some sound effects and some
basic stuff like that
This felt
Amazing you know it looks dreadfully
unimpressive like Well Done jackets you
stole the most simple game ever made I hope
you're trying to get stuff but myself I took
this game that exists in unity
Four dimensional rotational
Accent and my brain just have my ears and I
try to read about them so that was quite
difficult but I did discover this tool
broken function in unity
The most important thing is that I was
proving that I knew how to use unity and I
was also building my familiarity with the
tools the things I had to solve when I was
making that game I couldn't have done when I
started like I can now because I kind of
know where to put it and nowhere to look I
know it's time to Google
Somewhere to stop and I think right now
should we want to step three to stop
building my own games and Start experiment
and sure I'm going to run into problems that
are things I don't know how to do and there
are problems I will fix that I've got that
confidence and that comfort with the tools
now I understand Unity
At least play around and at the very least I
know what to type into Google or I know how
to construct a question for someone who is
National now I can't guarantee that this
style of learning will work for me everyone
learns in different way and maybe you do
just like having someone exciting to you
someone who gets very easily boards to
experiment and play around with things
Well let me know if that'll be useful in the
comments
Useful in the comments down below and if I
have time I might be able to swing in a
quick tutorial video to go along with this
series finale thank you so much for watching
Bear
Episode reviews
So a big goal with development what's to
give you a super transparent look at what
it's like to make your own video game and so
I've tried to show you every step of the
process from learning the game engine to
making your first prototypes from running
feedback sections too design problems I've
tried to show you everything so that you can
see what it might be like if you too Channel
For if you run into a programming problem
when you're working on your game you
probably don't have a huge Discord full of
people willing to help you out at the job of
a hat or direct access to the depths that
unity and if you need plane testers for your
game
You are inspired and influenced by my story
to go out there and try and make your own
games but I think before we dive into how
the game actually did I think it's worth
putting that that's the Restless
And so if you were to make your own game you
need to set your expectationsRealistically.
So in the last episode of developing I
hovered my mouse cursor over that big green
release app button and then on November 13th
at 5:00 p.m.
Playing a game right now which while they're
not exact sales numbers does give you an
idea of how popular okay minutes changed
So far
What's up how you been extremely press the
back button on my browser and went back to
the main theme set and realize that oh right
unlike the super delayed wish list numbers
valve does actually tell you pretty much up
to date comma
Because
Then valve would like its cut the company
wants 30% of your Revenue as a little thank
you gift for directing millions of people to
game infrastructure
One two three four five please
Now this money will end up in the gmtk
business bank account at some point
Imaginext Now videos
Exactly but living in the UK and paying
corporation tax that's going to be another
American one two three four 13 14 15
Minutes
Still a huge amount of money but it is a
little shocking and a little
Did you see this compared to the 100 that we
started with and so if you take nothing else
from this whole Development Center
Anytime soon because an influx of new
players means an influx of new bugs and as
soon as mine of magnet was out people were
being forums onto the GMT rooms period
The biggest deal in the world and that meant
I can take the first four days of the game
march to chest relax
Cover digest and sucked against
Perspective I thought of a much better wait
I mean I can probably repeat the same that's
that ridiculous some people will also having
trouble with the gameplay
Things that 99% of normal game players would
probably never run into but speedrunners
could use physics glitches and bugs to make
you need run faster or jump much much
happier and interesting to me and even
beyond that I decided to keep the release
version of the game
With a patch and then
I know nothing
I would like to do a console version next
year and least on the switch but no
immediate plans so please inevitable level
editor oh and speaking of inevitable did you
know that every YouTuber on the internet I
do have my own plush toy to try super
plushies super cute version of Magnus from
the game it is currently a few days later so
if you would do me a solid and all the one
let me fantastic otherwise
Please send me
Bro
Around every
About the numbers we talked about the money
Review which is pretty awesome though
probably slightly biased by
A bit more realistic but all of those
reviews are amazing really really happy to
be in terms of positive sentiment I think
people just generally do it was a fun video
game to play which is nice and found that at
least some of the puzzles produce that
satisfying haha moment I've been chasing
this time praise the general feel the Polish
the presentation the
Issue was definitely the length of the game
Mind of a magnet is about 2 hours long and
for some people that just less than wanting
more the others in wanting a reef and a few
people did take that opportunity but nearest
Money
Please
Ultimately I decided to just look at other
games of a similar length
And press the game with thoughts though I
make sure to always give myself enough
wiggle room for all of the inevitable launch
status
Bible with the rent development in the end I
haven't found that the game is playful and
enjoyable for a very general and Casual
audience of people it's right that I can
just give the game to anybody and they'll
probably be able to play at least the first
couple worlds and it's been great to see so
many people send me photos that kids
Nope that does not sound good at
And so that does feel good however I do
regret that I didn't have time to put in
content that was better suited to anymore
Safe uninspiring unimaginative which that
one did kind of catch me by surprise that
the more I think about it the more I can
kind of see what those people are coming
from I mean this game is not going to blow
yourself it is not the most Innovative game
of the year
Or even of November it is a pretty box
standard by the Numbers life that video game
and also as a solo developed project for the
most part
It's not a very personal experience you
don't get a lot of me in this game so while
I'm a little sad that people saw it in that
way I can at least understand
Better and you know what
That is kind of thing
But I wasn't 100% happy or confident with
the game but still putting it out there for
people to buy and play that's right and
review
The cringe is real and that's how I felt for
most of the first week of the game but
ultimately
I came to the realization that this was
never the point of developing it was not
about trying to make the best game ever made
of if I had done that by accident it was
hard to make it look good it was hard to
make it feel good it was hard to decide to
fix as someone who typically works on a
YouTube video for free weeks it was hard to
work on the same project and keep that
motivation going for three years
At various stages of completion basically it
is a miracle that this game even exists and
so the fact that it doesn't completely suck
Is just a nice bonus on top if you want me
but okay
By the end of development it was basically
effortless to put together or to change or
to iterate on one of the levels in this game
and so while this stuff certainly took
Suddenly took time to produce it saved so
much time down the mine and I don't regret
any of the time I spent building this tools
another good use of my time I think was
working on the juice that presentation the
Polish the game feel I don't think it's too
big-headed of me to say this game feels
pretty good to play and it's not nice
animations
Another big win was playtesting now all of
it it took me a long time for I was able to
show the game to anybody but once I did I
didn't really stop and over the course of
several years I constantly and consistently
showed the game to friends and family
members and strangers on Twitter and people
that events and meetups by listening to
feedback from other people be significantly
worse
If I just ignored what everyone thought of
again that should be obvious but that's
repeating I'm also pretty happy with
accessibility support it has full control
You can just skip any level in the game as
long as you've been stopping it for about
three or four minutes so the game never has
a total brick wall and there's no reason to
look up a guide leave the game
Was rushing too fast into production??????
Pre-production is that you could be really
fast and Nimble about making changes because
they're easy and fast and cheap you can try
10 different solutions to a design problem
and it doesn't matter because you just can
throw everything away anyway you're not
committed to anything that if you do what I
did and move too
Repeating yourself
Spending your wheels having to throw away
lots of love basically what I'm trying to
say is you shouldn't have to change all of
the art Assets in your game within the last
few months of development because you hadn't
previously figured out how a camera that is
and I believe this is a technical term
Dumb dumb decision another thing actually
entering option is that I never really had a
good plan for how to make the game no road
map no Milestones nothing of that game
didn't matter
And then switch to a controlled it will
continue moving from where that point was
Look like a day to figure out and is not
that important things and I wish I had spent
time another thing that went wrong
Like across innocent and I started to
realize that some of the world's greatest
puzzle game designers like Jonathan Blow and
Alan Hazelden Steven Lavelle have spent
years like that whole careers just learning
the Trump puzzle design yeah
And so it shouldn't be a surprise element
problems
Limited
Why you always messing with me
Do you want Infinity
You know
You sleeping alone so
Yeah
Will I make another game that is a question
I've been thinking about a lot lately and
it's a question that people asking are you
going to make another video
Not sure if I'm ever going to do but if Mind
Over magnet is
The only game I ever met
I'm okay shortcomings opportunity
It is a cool video game a real game that
went from idea to release and is now been
played by thousands of people
Bye
For me so
So I want to say a massive thank you to
everyone this watch this series as Watch Me
Slowly lose my mind and have supported the
game I want to thank you if you were there
in 20215 a.m. tomorrow
But I'm excited to find out
So much for watching don't forget about me
exclamation point
This season is better when we're together
Is this a commentary on where humanity is
headed
The street you up cuz you're a little broken
you have any great day you know since just
because the title talks about little
nightmares 3D oh that has to happen
To make this video 18 hours long
Time
A little nightmares 3 I don't think it's any
secret how I feel about this franchise
little nightmares setting special place in
my heart you know who doesn't live in my
heart at the end of two
Games
Little nightmare Street part 1 man let's put
this junk on about a 75 Edition
Let's get itAll right choose a character we
got this character. And then we got the
black.
Think it's a big surprise which one we're
going to go with you
Bro
Pay attentionYou got to lock it.
Let's figure out the story together
Sick you got some type of sickness I'm
paying attention to everything so I just got
to wait
In my control
Weapon see where I'm going with this
Again tutorial that you can do that I won't
beIt's me.
Put it in Boots
Like swallows to like see what's going on
So
It's Ebola
Reminders
The bond that we had with those characters
Just for me I'll put y'all almost right now
I'll send it up for something
Over here wait okay so with the ball out
can't jump oh okay okay I got to see thank
you
Frozen
What's happeningBecause the story.
We need questions
Don't trip don't know I hate that
OkayLook around using rice stick.
Please
I'm not trying to be freaked out over there
Question mark
Birds are hanging I'm really trying to come
at thisPiece of paper like the first thing.
Here
Pick the pressing right hereIt's like.
Fucking standing
Right
There we go thank youChipotle.
Bedroom
I'm going to bed my phone
Work please
Picking up
Yeah
See let's seeThe lock. With our fight. But
the door is.
Checks soWhat the hell.
Yeah
Birthday deserve itThat's good.
Somebody snoringOkay trying to jump on here.
All right.
Now
Deeper than running again
Do that anymore
Reminder
Let me see them but I'm hereWe'll be falling
in right now.
To get that wrench out there
Okay all right
Making umbrellas
So small peopleLike any birds and making
umbrellas.
Soon
Google
Singing in my ear right now
Mystical baby
Get this right
Stay With Me
Thanks it's only one way we're going to
survive this and that's together all right
before that happened
Celebrity suck my ass for weeks
I mean a freaking solitary confinement
Please
OkayUnited desert anymore like.
Here
That goes out goes out and it's another one
Start the baby LibertyI say wait.
Er
Completely
Sorry your mom didn't give you the right
formula
2 minutes
Can
Is that all rightDid she go with you.
All right I was just blowing you up cuz I
wanted to make sure that I have my mama
stuck at the airport
Yes yes
Mango
Okay
Switch it down there again when I switch it
either way I can get to the different menus
but all these buttons on the menu don't work
so I want all the buttons to work that's it
Just trying to make it easier becauseLike
that message with the command thing is kind
of lame.
And I prefer to justYou know what I'm saying
to get around.
You
Check my name
So how do you how you don't know where to
get you don't know they're not in your
pocket what you say you're not teacher
My Microsoft?.
Perfect shot in the dark at the
Discord buttons I just figured that they
didn't fix them all and that's probably more
so I'm going to continue to
Spam that message to this agentSo let's go
ahead and just grab that.
Send it a couple
Post and it's desperate in its step logs
then we know that agent 2 is active because
agent too
Just made a developOr even if we could track
every time an agent sends or receives.
Sends a message in the time so like if we
definitely if we do like the time oh got to
get that one real quick well I don't know
that might be unnecessary complexity but I'm
just thinking about a situation where we
take the
The logs and the time from when the agent
says something or not necessarily says
something but when they were supposed to
receive a message
I don't know if that worksWhen I think about
that a lot it just doesn't work because.
How will we know when the agent actually
receives it
See we can tell when it gets to the queue of
the agentAnd all we're doing is just killing
the Q.
InterestingSomething to think about
something to know but it's nothing that I
can do anything about right now it is.
It would be interesting to take the time of
when they sent the
Of when they sent the message and
Knowing of when they sent the message we
automatically know when they received the
message well
When it got implemented in the queue
It's hard because the the associated status
update that should come from that message
it's Dynamic and
It's really no clue or no telling
Okay
So we can disregard the fact of the sending
of the message as far as like a station
where we can tell an agent did something cuz
an agent doesn't have to do anything to
receive a message but we do know an agent is
active
I don't know where my markers are
No because we need to researchers and we was
going to answer if she can use the car so we
can go get the groceries because
When research is supposed to be the first
time she said
She said after hours she said about it so
that's what car was asking so I come down to
ask you
But if she said yeah
Never mind
Ariel poop you know who got this ball is
that the big bull or the small one
Oh yeah
Focus
Not exactly right now give me like
What happened to those sports that I
hadSomebody robbed me for my Forks Over.
I had forks I had a pork and at 24 I got you
working there was a pork over here I was
like I took my phone
It's